Donald Trump supporter and former New
York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani said that
not only is it wrong to call Donald
Trump racist it's wrong to call anyone a
racist going into the world of words
have no meaning and we can't truly know
anything speaking on MSNBC yesterday
morning he reacted to questions about
Donald Trump and racism in this way the
hate and the racism out of so many
people were saying racism there's no you
don't think Breitbart news Stephen bad
news not running for office but Steve
benen is the architect of Donald Trump
Donald what do you believe right what
everyone Donald Trump's campaign but
then what do you call the city of all
this stuff you throw around racist the
last thing in the world Donald Trump is
to the races I known for 28 years the
man likes white people he likes black
people he likes Hispanic people he plays
golf with him he opened up he opened up
the first Club in Palm Beach that
allowed Jewish people black people
Italian people like me who couldn't get
into those clubs to get in get into
those can you say that Steven [ __ ] guy
Ron Donald Trump's campaign he's Donald
Trump runs Donald Trump's game what's he
doing even pay your own vanity there are
a lot of people that do different things
but to say that Donald Trump is a racist
is outrageous and to call anybody a
racist is outrageous oh my god you can
call races I can't call him a racist
because the man has done more for
minorities over the last 30 years in
terms of opening facilities for them
hiring that promoting yeah Trump open
for profit facilities for minorities
he's the good guy here what does that
mean though to say it's outrageous to
call anyone races there is become where
according to Republicans calling someone
racist is worse than actually being
racist and if Donald Trump isn't a
racist then we have to look at whether
things he has done have
disproportionately negatively impacted
non-white people in this particular case
he's been sued multiple times because he
was blocking black people from renting
apartments in his buildings at least now
I guess we have the standard for racism
Pat which is hey Trump has played golf
with non-white people
he can't possibly be a racist and news
alert by the way as a general rule most
racist deny being racist and poor rudy
giuliani to he had such a fall from
grace i mean the guy was a popular mayor
of New York City yeah it actually looked
like he was gonna win the 2008
Republican nomination for awhile and
ever since he's just become a trump
apologist and it really doesn't look
good for him this is the guy who called
Trump a genius right it should should we
be skeptical of people who call Trump a
genius I think we should and I
completely disagree with the idea that
calling people racist is objectively
outrageous I do agree that it is hard to
know for sure what's in someone's head
right you don't know whether someone has
conscious racist beliefs or
subconsciously racist beliefs but the
idea that you can't use the term racism
when talking about others is very very
silly to me and what's fascinating is
that the right usually slams the left
for not being willing to call things
what they are because they don't want to
use certain terms right you hear the
right say Oh the left won't use this
term the left is afraid to use that term
but then they say oh you just can't be
calling people racist it's the exact
same type of thing that we're seeing
from Rudy Giuliani that usually they
critique the left for doing saying Oh
language policing is bad well there's a
lot of Republicans saying hey the use of
the term racist is just objectively
wrong bad an outrageous is Rudy Giuliani
saying the total double standard right I
mean you can't really look into
someone's head and see if they're racist
or not but you can look at the actions
that they've taken to and Trump is a guy
that has been sued repeatedly for
housing discrimination about upon a
bunch of other things the comments that
he's made gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with reach
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s